last week someone uh I think it was a
voicemail or maybe someone wrote to me
and said David do you think Herschel
Walker understands uh how the runoff
works and the fact that because no one
got 50 in Georgia now there's a runoff
just between him and and Raphael Warnock
I said I have no clue what Herschel
Walker does or doesn't understand but I
did have a curiosity as to what sorts of
public statements and appearances was
Herschel Walker going to make in this uh
intermediate period between the November
election and the December 6 runoff and
it's completely incoherent so I can't
tell you for sure whether Herschel
Walker understands the runoff but he
seems very confused about a bunch of
other things in this first clip Herschel
Walker says we are the best country in
the United States
I don't know that he's wrong about that
do you know we're the greatest country
in the United States in the world
because we have the United States
military yep we are the best country in
the United States and the world because
of the military then Herschel Walker
does seem to be suffering from a touch
of what we call the Trump delusion where
he believes only he can save America now
remember Trump said that Trump said only
he can help solve many issues I think in
2015 2016 Trump was saying only I can
fix health care we never even got his
health care plan uh only he can fix
trade and of course he didn't and this
seems to now be I don't know that a
requirement but it certainly seems
beneficial and to a degree it makes
sense if you are completely unqualified
hypocritical
unethical
clueless and have no business in elected
office you first have to convince
yourself that you have some business
running and in order to do that you
probably tell yourselves lies like the
entire country is depending on this and
that's exactly what he said to Larry
Kudlow I love the United States of
America if I do not win that seat we may
not recognize America as soon as they
get back in control because they seem
not to like America I want America to be
great I want every kid in America to
have that America's Dream well I can
tell you right now if I don't win that
seat no other American will ever have
that America dream again yep the entire
American Dream depends on Herschel
Walker who's completely unqualified and
doesn't know up from down when it comes
to policy if he doesn't win
no kid in America will ever achieve the
American dream that's a sickness that is
unique to the Republican party you hear
you know we talk about in many areas
Democrats and Republicans are more or
less the same and in other areas they're
very different
this particular sort of uh God complex
I don't see on the left I just don't see
it even Barack Obama who knew he would
be the first black president half black
of course as We Know
even when he was asked about like are is
this the most important thing a black
person whatever there was a statement
and he said well listen it's important
but think about all of these other
people and he listed a half dozen other
people this is a unique type of delusion
that you see on the right
here is a uh oh here's Walker again
continuing to talk about pronouns and I
I really don't know that he knows what
pronouns are I'm increasingly suspicious
but yet they bring it pronouns
they're bringing pronouns in our
military right so his pronoun gonna be
former Senator Pro now that's it pronoun
former Senator
Rafael warnock's pronouns are going to
be former Senator I have it on good
authority that if he wins Herschel
Walker is going to launch a brutal
assault on prepositional phrases the
likes of which you have never even
dreamed about Ted Cruz appeared
alongside Herschel Walker on Fox News
and he just kind of nodded along as
Herschel Walker made no sense and
visibly struggled to use language to
communicate He's a hypocrite and being a
pastor I say this how can he keep the
almighty old to the almighty God and
he'd keep it for them he hadn't kept it
for neither nobody so that proves the
type of man he really is all right so
Cruz you're the leader Ted Cruz's head
it's like a bobble head doll Locker here
you're going to have to open up some
holes for Herschel what yeah it's all
just so so so great guys and then here
is sort of like the cherry on top uh
Laura Ingraham on Fox News interviewing
Herschel Walker
they said we're in overtime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
Georgia is the third state that could
decide the fate of the Senate and with
its second runoff turns out it won't
right because Democrats held the Senate
since this interview aired in just as
many years it's also the second most
expensive racist cycle totaling 262
million dollars by the way one of the
things these right Wingers are able to
do is just turn a fact into like a a
criticism of Democrats this is a super
expensive race and they they act as if
that's proof that you should vote for
Walker in some way okay yeah the race
was expensive and Walker is incompetent
joining us now is the Republican
Herschel Walker who is really good in
overtime I have to say Georgia Senate
candidate Herschel great to see you
tonight as always
um how are you feeling right now after
this wild week where we have so many
races across the country still undecided
and you're heading to this runoff
well I feel pretty good uh the reason
why I'm still fighting for the people of
Georgia uh you know that's what I got in
this race about it was about the people
of Georgia that they were not
represented well in Washington we have a
senator that seemed to be representing
Washington our California New York not
Georgia and Georgia need a champion and
I'm that champion because I'm going to
get into Washington and let the people
voices be heard and let the people know
that they'll have that champion there
because Senator Walnut has not done it
since he went to Washington less than
two years people see where we're at
Herschel McConnell Mitch McConnell is
turning to Governor camp for help in
this race Politico is reporting that
Kemp is loaning his get out the vote
machine to the Senate's GOP voter
turnout efforts giving the party entree
I'm curious what he'll say about this
political team that is increasingly
viewed as one of the gop's most
formidable State operations and at the
same time we understand the Democrats
have already invested seven million
dollars in get out the vote efforts
which sounds like ballot harvesting to
me which is legal in your state
listen they're spending money on this
election there's got to be something
illegal there
um what's the way to win this race now
with the remaining weeks that you have
well you know it's such a short time and
uh you know the Democrat is trying to
buy this seat yeah exactly that money
spent by the Democrats is to buy the
seat whereas uh all the money spent on
the behalf of Herschel Walker is just
democracy or whatever the case may be
this is a crucial race it's now about 51
rather than 50 and making Joe manchin
irrelevant so we are going to be
following that race closely we are going
to be activating around that race we'll
have more information for you soon